it's been years decades at least since
I've been inside this house I lived here
when I was just a kid with my family my
mom my siblings my uh my dad received a
call from Tobias telling me that they
were finally ready with the repairs this
morning took them long enough
hey it's funny even after what happened
and all that time away from home it
looks just like I remembered it to be is
my memory that precise yeah of course
things like the furniture and photos
aren't here anymore
but hey can't blame anybody for that
right right I guess I better use that
memory for something useful I don't have
the full story nor do I know why it
happened but I can tell you how it
started everything else is up to you to
figure out this is the story that night
I lost my home my childhood and almost
my family win five nights at freddys
just ended what excuse you you gonna get
all metaphysical on me hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to the
joy of creation story mode now what you
saw in the past about the joy of
creation although it may have been
nightmarish was just a taste a demo of
what was to come this is the full
release of this game and so going into
this I don't even know what to expect
out of the story everything that I saw
in the early opening video was just kind
of an enigma that referred to five
nights at freddy's directly I don't know
what that means
so I guess I got to go into it and find
out it's done let's dive in I'm trying
to
oh ah the bedroom of the forgotten that
sounds morbid in my bedroom oh boy hello
hi my name is Margo bar are you doing
long story
oh you can't just barge into someone's
house just what are you doing in our
house
this song's about to go down I don't
think you should be here
[Music]
okay this seems weird so a stranger goes
into your house passes out dad carried
the stranger to a guest room he thanked
me for convincing my parents to let him
rest in our house for a night or at
least well I collected his thoughts
after that mom put me in bed I can't
remember much about Michael but I knew
he wasn't a bad person or at least he
didn't look you know dangerous I was
young so I guess I just didn't know any
better
certainly didn't know what a burglar was
that's for sure hmm not that I was
implying he was I never talked to him
again after that well except for when
the storm happened that's when I woke up
on my bed and I saw them mm what did
Michael bring with him straight from
five nights at freddys is that what
we're supposed to assume here is that
what that means space bar to stand up or
sit down Bruce left click to interact
with objects look up while sitting and
hold left click to sleep extra continue
escape not show again I don't know what
this is all about but I'm and I go for
it yes all right let's do this I guess
harrumph I got it Oh
hanging Little Nicky hits me Michael and
hey don't say anything back to me okay
there are monsters around let me hear
you if you do now
don't be scared make okay listen to me
and we can defeat those monsters all
right okay so these monsters might look
dumb Missouri Yama
don't look at them too long you'll feel
weird and secretly things when you do
turn on desk lamp miss your bed will
feel safe there but the more you stare
at the scary monsters the worsen feel
okay first things first
Freddy the fuzzy brown bear he's at the
window
yo get inside close your curtains and
keep them closed until you hear else
he'll get inside then there's Bonnie
bunny keep an eye on your door he'll be
there he's not shy at all you will knock
on the door to let you know he's there
but once he opens the door shut off the
lights as fast as you can Mickey you
can't see you well in the dark though oh
but make sure you're sitting down when
you do that right okay then there's the
chicken
that's a little bit weird check the
closets often if she's peeking through
make sure to disable the lights she
doesn't want to be seen but ignoring her
doesn't help either if she does catch
you with the lights on she'll scare you
and stun me now I know this is a lot to
take in little icky okay just just
listen carefully okay my last is Fox
oh right beneath your bed yeah you'll
hear scraping to the bottom of the crib
yeah be watchful if you see his hook on
the back of your bed cuz soon enough
you'll be right there next to the bed
don't look directly Adam Nick instead
and pretend asleep I just pretend asleep
yeah just lie down without moving too
much look up and close your eyes
Foxy's he's eyes as if they're big
bright spotlights you pretend to sleep
know you're there anymore but don't open
them until you know he's gone okay okay
so to recap Freddie is at the window so
if you see him peeking close the
curtains until he's gone Bonnie will
knock on the door and open it afterwards
disable the lights and sit down until he
leaves Chico will try to study by
scaring you so if you see her peeking
through the closet shut off your lights
and don't pretend to sleep she'll think
you're gone
and foxy will appear under your crib and
move upwards so when he's next to your
bed intend to sleep on all right you got
all that oh good listen I have to go a
little buddy okay just hang in there oh
they'll leave at 6:00 a.m. I'm sure of
it
you can do this
oh it's gonna be cut off right then
there and I'm gonna be left alone with
that information
I gotta deal with all them right away
well I have no idea I can't remember
which is which
swing swung this wing strong for Freddy
lights off for Bonnie and chica boy yeah
I know nan lights on for chica oh I have
no idea what any of this is about or
what I'm supposed to be doing here okay
I don't remember am I supposed to keep
that light on for any particular reason
any at all nope okay all right we're
just gonna pretend like everything's
okay and I'm not about to die uh what is
that I see something over there oh
that's a branch is that a branch but
that's a bridge that's not a grant
what are you okay I guess I got it turn
that off and sit down well that's not
good
try that again shall we I don't know
what I needed to do just gonna do this
trial by error because I don't think I
don't think it's gonna matter what I do
because I think I'm gonna die no matter
what so let's just do this
I think I remember it if I don't I'll
just die I'll keel over and die that'll
be great actually I won't keel over and
die I'll have my soul ripped out of my
body by animatronics all right so it's
for Freddy only when you see him do you
turn turn the curtains closed
turn off the curtains you gotta turn off
the curtains for Freddy that's how that
works and that's how logic is and then
for being bogging on the door door you
got to turn out the lights and make
Bonnie go bye-bye oh hi
excuse you what is that I don't know
what that is I don't know what you are
don't play peek-a-boo with me okay all
right well that's one for me in the wind
column a lot of losses but still you
know at least I'm in the game oh I'm not
here on the sleepy baby Oh boohoo my
nightmares are bad but I'm sleeping
they work I don't know if it worked when
am I supposed to turn the light on that
I don't know oh well that's quiet do you
don't need to but what was that what was
that what was that what was that okay
all right then hunga it works still
still works still works who's wearing
whose what huh I thought I saw hook I
don't know what the back of my crib is
okay that's I need who's there
leaping snakes knocks you're in for me
oh that's Oh
chica Oh Oh what are you I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I did what I don't know is what the
lights are for but Freddy is simple just
close the curtains when you think you
see him and I think I normally see like
a little bit of a body there the
scraping I know that's lie down
[Music]
you're done you're done you're done zou
you're done so I don't know I don't know
Bonnie has it
Bonnie hasn't even I don't know what you
owe your he's armed
oh no no you probably don't care if I
have my light on or off it's this is
curtains can't see no I'm still there oh
I'm uh burnick anyway so bring it on
oh hello welcome to the party sir good
to see you hey no how about you don't
hmm a bunch of dog you could not that'd
be great oh that was a sad moan into the
darkness oh ho
crushing disappointment it is bad go
away for a deal with it like we all do
I honestly have no idea what what is the
bing-bong tour me seriously what is it
Bing bong door mean I don't know I don't
know oh okay all right man moaning all
right again I don't know what hi hello
hi no thank you
go away I don't want it okay thank you
you actually listened to me which was
nice I think for Bonnie it's lights out
for tickets lights on I don't know hi oh
okay lights out I can't
okay yeah hi hello let your light is not
on
oh boy oh wait I'm not dead that's right
just stunned I forgot about that oh oh
oh oh turn out the light turn out the
light turn out the light turn out the
light I'm sleeping I'm sleeping oh I'm
so sleeping oh you are no Rama I don't
know if I'm doing anything right it's
only 1:00 a.m. what does the yellow
light mean I've no idea survive
hi okay I don't know what to do about
you
okay hi you actually coming in to vote
okay good job Bonnie go film yourself
oh hey how's it going gonna just do that
hi how you doing good good bro all right
well we got someone on the window
that's a scraping sound I don't like
that but until I see the hook I guess
I'm gonna go look no hook okay we're
still okay that was just a precursor
screed three scream what I'm making it
release um someone making it okay get
some light in here yeah that was good
all right how about some more raid okay
oh good the rain stopped everything can
be happy right oh that's that's that's
interesting in my house where I don't
think I have any other brothers or
sisters that could scream at that pitch
ooh okay I'll sit hey chica you do
that's not good that is
okay need to turn the light on cuz I
think I'm going crazy oh yeah I'm
shaking it's amnesia style baby how's it
going you know I'm just gonna look at
you I don't like this none
I like this exactly moon oh boy yeah
this is bad I need to mmm that light's
good mmm that light is oh oh why Freddie
why I need to get up right now mmm in my
eyes oh oh that's scraping okay it's
fine though it's fine
ah good like good like that's good light
why is this causing me to shake more
instead of less Oh Oh me things me go
crazy
whoa okay gonna sleep now lalalalala
I am NOT doing well
that's weird
oh no oh no oh no oh no I can't hear
anything
oh hi hello how are you doing that's
something that the door oh boy this bad
who's that blood Oh excellent a fine
vintage to that blood oh boy oh boy a
child should not be seeing blood oozing
from the two lean cut I gotta be quiet
because otherwise I'm not gonna hear
anything else my head oh boy that's a
lot of blood that's a lot of ceiling
blood something tells me I'm not gonna
make it oh sorry sorry chica it's okay
don't mind the blood hi what is that
that's I say old pipe yeah I think you
did I don't know what that is oh no oh I
can't move anymore
I'm dead I'm died died I died okay well
Oh what is this
okay all right I think I know what I
need to do so I need to keep the light
on at all times
oh that's that's what I would call bear
okay hi chica welcome to the party -
okay well why don't we just get
everybody in there I'm about to lose my
mind
where's the blood hmm oh there it is
right on cue can you close the door
please
thank you anyone else here no oh that's
perfect we're fine
oh yeah that's good oh it is oh hi hello
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
that's terrifying
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that is [ __ ]
terrifying fine fine we can make it
maybe ooh hello you're not there you're
not really there anyway maybe that that
was oh that's oh I gotta sleep right
I'm not dead though I'm not dead yet
where's my Oh goddamnit how close was I
oh I must have been so close almost been
so close okay we're fine we're fine
we're fine
we're gonna make it we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it I'm gonna make it
we're gonna make it oh boy it's about to
start
what we're doing much better than we
have been in the past we're fine okay oh
boy oh boy I got a hold on come on six
[Music]
do you say five nights at Freddy's
crater commemorate the occasion by
releasing Brendan behind the scenes
what does it mean why is it so many it's
so real-world
I mean that sounds like a funeral longer
not a happy bummer oh that sounds like a
sad longer alright thank you
ok I guess that's that
Oh what's next what is next living so
the living room is next and there's four
more levels so I'm going to finish this
game this is really good stuff and for
being free this game is free like all
these five nights at Freddy's fan games
this is free and he's so interesting and
it's good mechanics and it's actually
scary so I can't wait to play more so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of it down
in the comments below if you want me to
play more let me know down there as well
you can find this game for yourself in
the description thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]